Do you think you are an adventurous person?
If yes, how does this sound to you?
Taking a shower with an elephant!
This is a good opportunity that you should not miss when you are in Laos.
Luang Prabang has been made a World Heritage Site in 1996...
...and is one of the most beautiful areas in Laos.
It attracts many visitors, local and foreign,...
...especially during Pimai Lao, the New Year celebrations in mid-April.
Ban Xieng Lom Elephant Village was set up in 2003.
The focus of this sanctuary is on saving the elephants,...
...supporting the local community and preserving nature.
You can do a mahout course and learn to ride these huge and beautiful animals.
You can take a trip to the waterfalls or through the forest to the river,...
...where you can wash the elephants.
This will be an amazing experience for you!
For a picnic lunch, you may have delicious chicken fried rice baked in banana leaves.